vogliate scusarmi se nel video youtube
sta morendo avevo questo riquadro in
faccia che mi seguiva ho scoperto che si
toglie facendo così avvicinando la mano
al sensore questo vi fa capire che quel
video lo registrato con una velocità
estrema avevo appena preso a videocamera
quindi ho provato a registrare due robin
croce gameplay e questa cosa qua mai
avrei pensato che quel video vi
realizzasse così tanto indi per cui devo
fare un ulteriore video di spiegazione a
tutte le risposte che mi sono arrivati
chiedo scusa se un cerotto gigantesco
che mi complimento a faccia però provate
a indovinare quand'è che lo devo tenere
questo devo quando il mio nome viene
sbattuto ovunque quindi devo fare un
video di risposte sono costretto a farlo
ovunque sua che tempismo incredibile per
avere un cerotto in faccia fate finta e
non esiste per chi non sapesse di cosa
stiamo parlando
qualche giorno fa ho fatto un video
chiamato youtube sta morendo punto
interrogativo dove spiegavo il fatto che
su youtube ci fosse un bug un sacco di
canali nell'ultimo periodo cui cerca
nell'ultimo mese sono scesi del 30 40
per cento di visualizzazioni totali sui
video io ho ipotizzato che questa cosa
fosse un problema mio vero che io nel
tempo magari facendo le stesse cose la
gente si annoia quindi magari mi segue
un po di meno che ci sta se non che a un
certo punto confrontandomi con altri
youtubers con tantissimi altri youtubers
è uscito fuori che questo calo
improvviso c'è per tutti quanti o almeno
per tutti quelli con cui ho parlato io
ea tutti quanti è iniziato più o meno
nello stesso periodo all'inizio di
ottobre circa qualche giorno fa ho visto
il video di mark player che questo
youtuber da sacco di milioni di iscritti
che ipotizza che questo bug sia dovuto
al alla scissione di google plus da
youtube ed è arrivato il momento di
precisare alcune cose la prima ho fatto
questo video per rispondere a tutti gli
youtubers che mi hanno posto la domanda
fa vigeva come mai siamo calati così
tanto all'improvviso si vede che hanno
chiesto a me perché essendo youtuber con
più iscritti in italia magari pensano
che io ne sappia di più
in realtà non è così però ho cercato di
dare una mano e di capire più o meno
quale fosse il problema visto che
interessa anche me per rispondere a loro
fondere anche a voi molti youtubers mi
hanno appoggiato altri invece affermano
che ho trattato l'argomento con troppa
superficialità quel video è stato molto
superficiale perché non avrei mai
pensato che avrebbe viralizzato così
tanto se l'avessi saputo prima mi sarei
documentato tantissimo di più però è
registrato in 10 minuti e quindi oggi mi
trovo a dover mettere i puntini sulle i
perché non l'ho fatto in quel video
giustamente la primissima cosa che io
voglio trasmettervi in questo video che
nell'altro video magari non sono
riuscito a fare e che io non ho fatto
questo video per vittimismo cioè io non
ho voluto dire ok youtube non mi fa fare
più le views
che schifo no e nel video non troverete
una parola contro youtube
l'unica cosa che rimprovero in questo
caso a youtube e il non comunicare dei
cambiamenti l'unica cosa per il resto io
duck da youtuber non posso pretendere a
che youtube fili liscio per sempre
perché tutto questa avventura di youtube
è iniziata senza pretese iniziata per
caso e come tale può finire e io non ho
diritto di dire a youtube audio iniziato
per gioco ho iniziato senza pretese
quindi ben venga tutto quello che viene
e poi se un giorno mai dovesse finire
dirò bella lì è stata una bella
cavalcata ma in un cielo con youtube
anzi io sono grato ogni giorno a youtube
per avermi dato questa opportunità sono
nel mondo dei videogiochi quindi il
mondo che amo quindi io non mi lamenterò
mai di youtube per delle cose che
youtube decide di fare perché non ne ho
il diritto quindi punto a capo per il
medesimo motivo
rispondo anche a quelle persone che
pensavano avessi fatto questo video per
cercare di trovare un capro espiatorio
per il calo delle virus della serie a le
mie viso stanno calando
non è un problema mio è un problema di
youtube perché io non posso mai calare
no non era quello l'intento è a me di
questo calo di youtube
così come ho detto nel video precedente
me ne frega non dico niente ma quasi
niente perché comunque io continuo a
fare 30 milioni di visualizzazioni i
mensili che sono tantissime sono proprio
l'ultima persona che si può lamentare
l'ultima persona che deve essere
consolata perché un sacco di gente mi ha
scritto dai propri geni tirati su
tranquillo che ti segue ragazzi
tranquilli quel video non l'ho fatto
perché ero triste perché dovevo andare
contro qualcuno non l'ho fatto per
quell'ora certo se non ci fosse stop
problema sarebbe meglio ma i problemi
nella vita sono altri non è questo il
problema ci tengo che sia veramente ben
chiaro poi se volete poter pensare che
mi rode il culo perché mi calano le
views anche se io non sono proprio quel
tipo di persona anzi a me la popolarità
mi fa anche abbastanza schifo quindi se
un giorno dovesse finire tutto
direi bel ali è stato figo se un giorno
dovesse morire veramente il mio canale
cosa che non sta succedendo quindi
andiamo
parliamo invece di un errore che ho
commesso nel video precedente di aver
trasmesso delle informazioni date per
certe invece che è puntualizzare il
fatto che fosse un ipotesi perché era
un'ipotesi in realtà non mi sono
spiegato bene volevo puntualizzare
questa cosa io non so se il problema è
veramente google plus
guardando il video di mark player mark
player ipotizza che il problema possa
essere la scissione di google plus
quindi io di riflesso ipotizzo ma io non
sono sicuro che sia questa la
motivazione però ci tengo a precisare
una cosa questo problema di youtube del
calo delle views non è colpa nostra
perché perché questo calo non è avvenuto
gradualmente e questa cosa io l'avevo
già specificata non ricordo il giorno
preciso io ho detto il 6 ottobre
nell'altro video ma lo sparata perché
non sono stato ad approfondire bene
forse anche un pelo prima forse a fine
settembre non so quando il mio canale
come quello di tantissimi altri
dall'oggi al domani ha perso il 3 nel
mio caso al 25 però in certi casi il 30
40 per cento delle views a caso
dall'oggi al domani per tre quattro anni
di fila i miei video in 24 ore facevano
tutti i 300mila virus è più o meno 283
120 con che intorno ai 300mila a meno
che non fosse un video virale tipo una
parodia prendiamo un giorno ipotetico
ipotetico vivido hanno sempre fatto 300
mila visti in un giorno sempre 300 mila
e 300 mila e 300 mila euro 300.000 views
28 settembre 300.000 views 29 settembre
200.000 views 30 settembre 200.000 views
primo ottobre 200 mila 200 mila e 200
mila e 200 mila in tre anni di views
fisse
fisse siamo passati da un joe dall'oggi
al domani proprio dalla notte al mattino
successivo ad un calo del 30 per cento
più o meno non gradualmente a caso non
c'è stato un cambiamento di niente non
c'è una motivazione in particolare
perché se questa cosa fosse successa
gradualmente cioè se negli ultimi tre
anni fossi passato dai 300mila e 200mila
nell'arco di tre anni nell'arco di due
di un di un anno nell'arco di sei mesi
non lo so in un periodo di tempo in cui
la linea statistica fosse stata del
genere quindi pian piano scendi vuol
dire che i miei contenuti pian piano
iniziano a stancare quindi devo cambiare
ma se la linea fa così c'è un evidente
problema come potete pensare che sia
colpa nostra poi non solo a me a persone
che fanno contenuti diversi anche da me
qualcosa che fanno make up persone che
fanno recensioni di cose c'è gente che
fa gameplay tipo man a gente che fa cose
diverse nello stesso periodo ma con
periodo intendo giorni anno fa hanno
avuto questo calo improvviso quindi i
casi sono due o c'è un bug tra
virgolette adesso andiamo a definirlo
bene che è successo un determinato
giorno oppure il 30 40 per cento della
nostra utenza dal mercoledi al giovedì è
morta morta nel sonno è morta nel sonno
questo è l'unico modo cioè non è che la
gente durante la notte dorme e dal
mattino si sveglia di shabab e basta
questo la metà delle persone che ci
segue lo è chiaro che c'è qualcosa che
non va
devo spiegarlo davvero non sono io che
devo giustificare il mio calo e devo
usare quel bug come capro espiatorio è
che c'è un evidente problema fra la
mente però il video realizzato da fa
dice intitolato youtube sta muovendo a
differenza degli altri contenuti è
finito nelle prime posizioni in tendenza
e ha raggiunto in tre giorni ben 670
mila visualizzazioni questo bug è
improvvisamente sparito perché se io non
soffrisse di questo bug
il video in questione invece di aver
totalizzato 750.000 views ne avrebbe
totalizzato 1,2 milioni questo perché i
miei video in generale quando vi
realizzano così tanto facevano quelle
views lì cioè quel video lì in un giorno
ha fatto 300 mila quelle che facevo
prima
adesso le 300mila sono diventate
l'eccezione in positivo non è proprio
come dici tu riccardo loccia ci sta come
ragionamento ma non è così c'è il video
soffre del bug per quanto sia virale vi
giuro su dio che se il problema fosse
mio se il mio caso fosse stato così io
sarei la prima persona a dire o cambio
modo di fare video se poi piacciono bene
se poi continua a fare così ovvio prima
o poi dovrà finire sta cosa e va
benissimo
va benissimo soggiorno dovesse veramente
finire bella lì c'è nel senso io ho
fatto tutto quello che per me è stato
possibile e non potrò mai in troverà mi
niente anzi ma non è questo il caso si
comunque un evidente problema che io non
posso ignorare
cioè non posso andare dagli atelier e è
la gente si è stancata
perché non è così io nell'altro video
ipotizzato quella cosa di google plus
potrebbe essere un'altra cosa potrebbe
essere semplicemente che youtube ha
cambiato da un giorno all'altro
l'algoritmo e quindi non consiglia più
determinati video magari i video
gameplay horror quelli che faccio io
ma preferisce consigliare i video di me
contro te non lo so they make up perché
e youtube una certa dice vabbè non
vogliamo che la piattaforma in vecchi
che portino sempre le stesse cose quindi
cerchiamo di indirizzare l'utenza di
youtube della piattaforma in generale su
altri contenuti quindi non voglio che i
contenuti di fa vj compaiano più così
tanto nei correlati quindi mandiamo meno
field a quelle persone che secondo
felice mandiamolo di più ad altra gente
questa potrebbe essere un'altra ipotesi
a quanto vi faccia strano sentirmelo
dire ma va bene perché se youtube decide
di fare una cosa io sono io a dovermi
adattare a youtube quindi sono io a
dover cambiare il mio contenuto non è
youtube a doversi adattare a me perché
sono io che sono entrato dentro youtube
in un certo momento della mia vita non a
youtube che ha bussato alla mia porta e
mi ha detto ciao fa vj fi video per noi
non è
quindi io mi devo adattare io non ho il
diritto di nulla però non può nessuno
venirmi a dire che la colpa è mia
scese da un giorno all'altro è successa
questa cosa è successa per cause di
forza maggiore
c'è caos su youtube non avesse toccato
nulla su youtube fosse si fosse messa
con le mani dietro la schiena
le mie views sarebbero sempre 300 mila
al giorno
loro hanno toccato qualcosa e quel
qualcosa mi fa fare
il 30 per cento in meno delle a me ad un
sacco di altre persone non tutti ed è
innegabile che sia così perché è
successo da un giorno all'altro quindi
non sono io che devo trovare un capro
espiatorio perché mi calano le views che
non me ne frega un cazzo
non me ne frega quasi un cazzo detto
questo non so se un giorno youtube
deciderà di rimettere le cose a posto
quindi di rimettermi video di più nei
correlati di farlo con tutti youtubers
in questione ma che succede o no per
adesso siamo noi a doverci adattare a
questo cambiamento se le cose stanno
veramente così perché youtube non ha
dichiarato niente questa è l'unica cosa
che un po rimprovero se non a youtube
avrebbe dovuto dircelo in qualche modo
non per perché sono obbligati a farlo
pagata non sono obbligati a farlo ma per
correttezza
detto questo tra poco sul mio canale
usciranno delle serie nuove che si
discostano dal gameplay proprio per
vedere di riuscire ad andare incontro a
questa cosa magari migliora magari no
divertiamoci perché youtube alla fine e
intrattenimento non problematiche a meno
che non siate break in italy ringrazio
tutti youtubers in questione per aver
preso parte a questo discorso io ripeto
questo problema e tocca un po di più gli
youtubers che piccoli quindi quelli che
a fine mese arrivano a stento a
raggiungere uno stipendio con i propri
video quindi adesso hanno un problema
molto più grave che che il mio canale
io vivo lo stesso quindi per quello non
ho motivo di fare video del genere per
andare contro youtube
io sono contento così domani c'è un
altro video che faccia 300 mila visti in
un giorno non ne faccia 200 sticazzi
avrò sicuramente dimenticato qualcosa in
questo discorso però non so se farò un
terzo video in questione perché farne
averne fatti due proprio l'eccezione
assurda non farò mai un terzo video che
vi sia piaciuto domani ci vediamo con un
altro vita quasi se vi è piaciuto
non mi piace anche visto alcuna
descrizione scusatemi per il cerotto che
ci dobbiamo fa youtube mi ha ferito
molto di più di quanto pensate da
ragazzi